[Music]
welcome to Koch news featuring the most
important information from Hollywood and
more this week Disney is embarking on a
liveaction marathon Netflix is now
filming avatar The Last Airbender after
the success of One Piece kickass is set
to get a reboot and the Gargoyles will
soon be seen again as a liveaction
series there's also news about the Kings
man Sequel and the Halloween Cinematic
Universe sounds interesting well then
stay
tuned
update on the Kings man with the prequel
the Kings Man released in 2021 director
Matthew vaugh introduced us to the
origins of the popular agent
organization now a second part will
follow which will focus on Hitler's rise
to power with kingsman the secret
service director Matthew vaugh released
one of the most popular movies of the
year in 2014 which not only turned out
to be a worldwide success but also Mark
the start of a new franchise then we
were treated to the king's man a prequel
starring Ralph fines which dealt with
the backstory of the agent organization
although the movie was not a great
financial success Von seems to still
have faith in the potential of his
franchise and now announced a sequel
during the New York ComicCon in an
interview with collider he reported that
the next part will deal with the rise of
Hitler who already made an appearance in
the mid-credit scenes of the predecessor
the latter is played by the German actor
David Cross vau Wanted the movie to be a
reminder of the dangers of fascism and
Drew parallels to the present day saying
I look at the world at the moment
everyone getting distracted and worrying
about this and that and if you worry too
much about this bad things can happen
here while the director obviously has
many creative ideas for the next chapter
of his action franchise up his sleeve it
remains unclear for now whether the
Traer King will be produced as a feature
film or as a TV series so fans of vaugh
should get their money's worth in the
next few years since after all with
Kingsman 3 and the reboot of kickass two
more projects have been announced that
are already being eagerly
awaited asses are being kicked once
again with the superhero satire kickass
director Matthew Bon may have completely
shaken up the superhero genre in 2010
the extremely cynical film not only came
with a fair amount of violence but also
helped actors Aaron Taylor Johnson and
Khloe Grace morrettes achieve their
breakthrough in Hollywood now a reboot
is to follow with part three which could
also cause another sensation it's been
10 years since we were given a sequel to
the popular predecessor in the form of
kickass 2 although the movie did not
really come close to the level of the
first kickass it was still quite
successful and therefore fans wondered
if and when a third part would follow at
this year's New York ComicCon director
Matthew vaugh finally lifted the secret
around kickass 3 and announced that
another part will indeed follow in an
interview with The Hollywood Reporter
Von revealed that part three will be a
reboot and will present us with new
characters a return of Aaron Taylor
Johnson Khloe Grace morrettes or
Christopher minz PL is currently not
planned as the reboot is deliberately
meant to go in a totally different
direction nonetheless it would not be
out of the question to bring back the
characters in a later part speaking to
sci-fi Von stressed that kickass 3 would
be something that had never done before
in terms of movies and that ideally they
would like to start shooting in early
2024 whether the movie will be able to
convince without the popular characters
Kick-Ass and hit girl remains to be seen
however Bon assured that we can expect
some great fun that will be talked about
for quite a while we can't
wait after the success of One Piece now
comes Avatar while the pirate series one
piece continues to enjoy great
popularity the next big liveaction
adaptation avatar The Last Airbender is
already in the pipeline Netflix has now
published a number of new images that
shows us the antagonists of the series
The live action remake of the popular
anime series avatar The Last Airbender
is likely to be one of the biggest and
most hotly anticipated projects for
which the streaming service Netflix will
be responsible next year there is
considerable skepticism since the first
live-action version of The Last
Airbender was released in 2010 and did
not enjoy a good reputation among fans
the success of One Piece should
nevertheless provide for a more
optimistic attitude towards the Avatar
series and the first images that showed
us the main characters of the series
were also very convincing now the
streaming giant Netflix is back with a
bunch of new photos this time featuring
The antagonists the Fire Nation so we
see actor Daniel Day Kim in the
distinctive outfit of fire lord oai Paul
son hyung Lee as fan favorite uncle iro
and Ken Yung as Commander Z princess
aula who is played by newcomer Elizabeth
Yu is set to make a strong impression as
is actor Dallas Leu as Prince Zuko who
hunts down the Avatar the liveaction
version of avatar The Last Airbender
does not have an exact release date at
present but it is expected to debut in
2024 the first season will consist of
Eight Episodes and it can currently be
assumed that the adaptation will be
based on the first season of the
original
anime Disney's live action campaign is
set to continue according to First
rumors a number of further remakes are
to follow including Tarzan the mega hit
Frozen as well as the Princess and the
Frog and Tangled the rumor that Disney
apparently wants to make a number of
other animated films has been
circulating on the internet for several
days the target is said to be movies
that continue to enjoy great popularity
among fans The Insider reports that four
new liveaction remakes are in the works
remakes of Tarzan Frozen Tangled and the
Princess and the Frog are said to be on
the company schedule and are already in
an early stage of development since
Disney has not yet commented on the
rumors this announcement should be taken
with a grain of salt it would be
feasible nonetheless since we can expect
a multitude of remakes in the next few
years all of which are based on the
cartoon and animation Classics rumors
about the remake of Tangled have been
going on for several months and Florence
Pew is said to have been cast as the
Disney Princess we will keep on
monitoring further
developments the Gargoyles are coming
back the popular animated series which
aired from 1994 to 1997 and must have
enriched the the afternoons of many
young people is receiving a reboot it
will be directed by two outright horror
experts the gloomy animated series
gargoyles which is about a group of
monstrous Warriors is probably one of
the most popular and special animated
Productions of the 9s along with
DuckTales and Darkwing Duck as The
Hollywood Reporter informs Disney is
currently planning to bring back the
iconic Stone monsters via a liveaction
reboot for which James Juan and Gary
Doberman will be in charge with their
production company Atomic monster Juan
and men are regarded as experts in their
field and have already teamed up on
several occasions including the Annabel
franchise The Conjuring prequel the nun
as well as the recently released Megan
it remains unclear when exactly the
series will come out currently the
project is still in a relatively early
stage of development and will therefore
probably take some time to complete
however we will make sure to keep you up
to date as
always Michael Myers is coming home
after a long back and forth the
Production Studio Miramax was able able
to acquire the television rights to the
Halloween franchise and is now planning
an entire universe that will comprise
both movies and series Miramax will be
in charge of several Halloween TV
projects in the coming years the
Production Studio was able to win the
rights in the course of negotiations and
has signed a wide-ranging contract with
tranis for the development and
co-production of a Halloween TV series
which is to usher in an entire Cinematic
Universe Mark Helwig head of Global TV
at Miramax will provide creative
oversight for the franchise
working closely with tranis
International films Executives tranis
most recently produced the Halloween
feature film Trilogy for Miramax and
blumhouse directed by David Gordon Green
in an interview with deadline Mark
Helwig expressed his excitement about
the future of the franchise we are
thrilled to expand our long and
successful partnership with tranis and
the brilliant mik akad in introducing
this iconic franchise to a new form of
Storytelling and a new generation of
fans mirax and Halloween have been
associated with each other for ages as
the Production Studio has been behind
all 13 movie adaptations of the
franchise through hell to Paradise this
is the path taken by the character Dante
played by Oscar Isaac in the new crime
Thriller in the hand of Dante which may
be released as soon as next year in the
hand of Dante tells the story of The
Scholar Nick who was hired by the mafia
to check the authenticity of the popular
manuscript of Dante alagiri The Divine
Comedy in parallel the story of Dante
himself is also told who fleas to Sicily
to begin writing his work the movie will
be produced by the great Martin Scorsese
and directed by Julian Schnabel who
already impressed with his biopic at
eternity's gate as deadline reports the
movie will have an impressive cast Oscar
Isaac is to assume the role of Dante he
will be joined by Jason Mamoa gal gdau
and action star Gerard Butler thanks to
a provisional agreement with sag Afra
production has already begun and filming
is currently taking place in Venice so
the chances are good that the film could
already celebrate its Premiere next year
that's it for this week's news but
should you want to know more check out
our latest original on our Channel where
we present the best upcoming horror
movies in 2023 and 2024 to look forward
to just in time for Halloween season and
what do you guys think can Netflix or
Disney convince with their all new
liveaction projects and are you excited
to see more of kickass let us know in
the comments see you next week for more
Hollywood
news
[Music]